bienvenidos a este examen número 8 esta
sección número 8 y estamos en la segunda
parte por cierto hablando de muchos
otros estamos en el problema número 8 y
dice cuántos grados más hay en un cuarto
de círculo que en un quinto del círculo
okay cuántos grados hay en un cuarto de
círculo bueno pues es tener un cuarto y
ya esto multiplicado por 360 grados
estás de acuerdo que darle una vuelta
entre el círculo son 360 y se me voy a
tomar solamente un cuarto del círculo
entonces voy a multiplicar a esto por un
cuarto y esto lo mismo que a 90 grados
90 grados sólo puede ser tú mismo 1 por
360 es un 360 entre 4 son 90 grados
además recuerda que cuando nosotros
tenemos un círculo lo partimos en cuatro
no salen ángulos de 90 grados
ok ok y por otra parte cuánto hay en un
quinto del círculo bueno pues aplicando
lo mismo va a ser un quinto por 360
grados lo voy a tomar de estos 360
grados los voy a dividir entre 5 y me
voy a tomar solamente una de estas
partes
igual a cuantos 360 entre 5 7 7 % 35
llevamos un lado aquí bajo el 0 son 2 2
por 5 10 entonces tengo de residuos 0 72
grados ok 72 grados ahora cuánto hay de
diferencia entre 90 grados y 72 grados
justo es mi respuesta 90 menos 72 lo
cual me da 18 grados 18 grados es la
respuesta a este problema que es el
inciso b
así que ya empezamos con el pie derecho
porque ya tenemos el problema número 8
así que vamos a hacer ahora el problema
número 9 el problema número 9 que tiene
la gráfica siguiente vamos a hacer la
gráfica del problema número 9 tengo dos
ejes por aquí uno y el otro programa ok
esta es mi hija
smg x bien este es mi x y tengo a una
función parecida a ésta déjame ver si me
sale empiezo por aquí sube baja
pasa por el origen y después a baja sube
y sigue subiendo así y bueno tenemos
algunos puntos yo sé que este punto de
aquí déjame ponerlo con otro color este
punto de aquí es el punto menos 6.0 ok
bueno este es el origen y este de aquí
es el punto 60 y además me dicen que
este punto aquí es el 76 76 ok a mí que
me preguntan con la gráfica siguiente
contesta para que valores de x f x es
negativa para que valores de x f de x es
negativa bueno pues fíjate en esta
gráfica si nosotros fijamos en fx
negativa estamos diciendo que llegues
negativa recuerda que éste es igual fx
ok y entonces como estoy comparando a fx
con x donde fx es negativo es en esta
parte de acá abajo todos los que están
acá abajo abajo del eje de las x son mis
valores negativos todos estos de aquí
son mis valores negativos ahora como los
puede obtener bueno pues date cuenta que
a estos son los valores de x que están
entre este punto y este punto en este
punto que es el origen ok
y cuáles son valores que están entre
estos dos puntos
bueno pues son todas las equis que son
más grandes que 0 y ojo son más grandes
que 0 pero no son iguales que 0 porque
justo cuando x vale 0 que vale 000 no es
un valor negativo yo lo que estoy
buscando son solamente los valores
negativos de fx y bueno fd x es negativo
cuando equivale a un número mayor que 0
pero menor que 6 justo aquí le paramos
pero menor que 6 y date cuenta que por
la misma razón no puede ser 6 porque en
el valor de 6 a nuestra función vale 0 y
entonces a él no es un número negativo y
por lo tanto no hay que tomarlos al 6
muy bien estos son los valores para los
cuales funciona que fx es negativa los
valores de x y es el inciso b el psoe me
dice justo esto ok el número 9 vamos a
ser el problema número 10 el problema
número 10 y dice hoy tenemos una figura
muy extraña y la vamos a ocupar vamos a
leer el problema
la figura siguiente muestra las
dimensiones de un pedestal construido
con capas de mármol donde cada capa es
un sólido rectangular con una altura de
un metro y tiene una base cuadrada
cuántos metros cúbicos si si si si hay
que dibujar la aunque vamos a dibujar
primero tenemos un cubo algo más o menos
así así así así va para acá va para acá
sube para cada mercado ok y después
abajo de este cubo tenemos el siguiente
piso que tiene a una base de dos cubos
algo más o menos así y no le gusta algo
un poquito más grande lo voy a hacer más
grande después algo así ok tengo una
base de dos cubos vamos a ver si me
queda algo más o menos así después éste
suben estos dos se unen esta es una para
acá este baja más o menos así estos dos
se unen ok o no estos dos se unen más o
menos por aquí ok
está en baja y éste sube ok algo más o
menos así y así tengo ahora una base una
base con dos cubos ok y puedo yo hacer
la siguiente a la siguiente parte de
este pedestal que es una base con tres
cubos pero aunque te parece si de una
vez vamos calculando el volumen de este
pedestal pues el volumen de este cubo
que tengo que llevar bueno que cada uno
de sus lados vale 1 1 1 y 1 el volumen
de este cubo es 1 ya esto le voy a sumar
el volumen de esta parte de abajo y cuál
es el volumen de esta parte de abajo
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que tener un
largo de 2 aquí tengo 1 y 1 aquí tengo
un ancho de 2 1 y 1 y una altura de 1
por lo tanto estos dos por 2 por 1 lo
cual es
2 por 2 por 1 es 4 ok y después viene el
siguiente piso el siguiente piso tengo
una base de 3 de lado entonces tengo
algo más o menos así algo más o menos
como por acá esto va para acá ok más o
menos así estos se unen algo más o menos
así
después tengo este por acá ok este por
acá
y me falta esto por acá ok algo más o
menos así y también tengo una altura de
un metro entonces se ve más o menos así
ok este sube porque creo que tú me vas
agarrando la onda más o menos de cómo se
ve en cada una de estas partes de esta
base este va para cam aquí tenemos tres
esto baja esto baja también ok y por acá
está baja más o menos así y éste también
baja ok se ve más o menos así tengo una
base de 3 x 3 x 1 de altura así que si
yo quiero calcular cuáles dejen por esta
parte de aquí si yo creo calcular pues
el volumen de este tercer piso bueno
pues date cuenta que tengo tres cubos de
uno cada uno
23 por lo tanto tengo un largo de tres
tengo un ancho de 3
123 y tengo una altura de 1 lo que
quiere decir que el volumen de este
tercer piso es 3 por 3 por 1 y esto es a
9 entonces a 4 le voy a sumar 9 que es
el volumen de este tercer piso y vámonos
al cuarto piso y el cuarto piso se va a
ver muy parecido tengo algo así tengo
algo por acá que más o menos así este va
hasta acá
ok
tengo una altura de 1 más o menos como
por acá a algo así algo así después
éstos suben estos o se unen tarde o
temprano ok y después este segundo para
acá tiene a lo mismo de ancho entonces
se unen o esto me quedó un poco raro
bueno pero más o menos se ve así ok y
después aquí tengo a este estaba mucho
menos decir estaba más o menos así
estaba más o menos así y después este
segundo con este segundo
este se une con este key y después éste
se une con éste esto se une con este
éste se une con este game éste se une
para que abajo algo así este también
para que abajo algo así y este también
para que abajo algo así de tal manera
que tengo cuatro cubos abajo y cuatro
cubos de largo así que si nosotros que
escuchamos el volumen de este último
piso pues esto es lo mismo que déjame
cambiar de color voy a tomar este color
tengo 1 2 3 4 x 1 2 3 4 y tengo una
altura de 1 es decir esto es lo mismo
que 4 x 4 x 1 si quiero calcular el
volumen de este último piso y 4 x 4 x 1
es lo mismo que 16 es decir que
esencialmente me tengo que tomar la suma
de
149 más 16 y esto es la suma de 1 459
estos 14 14 16 son 30 30 metros cúbicos
tiene en total
este pedestal que tengo justo aquí y ya
está esa es la respuesta de este
problema el problema número 10 tienen
como respuesta 30 metros cúbicos y por
cierto este es el piso se ya está estuvo
bastante complicado para dibujar y creo
que por esto no fue arquitecto pero ya
están aquí tengo el problema número 10
así que vamos a trabajar en el siguiente
problema en el problema el número 11 ok
este 1 aunque dominicial a problemas
número 11 vamos bien dice
si x y jenson entre los positivos y se
cumple que 4 por 2 elevado a la equis
esto es igual a 2 elevado al aiem cuanto
es x en términos de gemma bueno aquí
tengo este 4 raro entonces lo primero
que yo haría es escribir todo en
términos de la misma base y el 4 los
buenos que también lo puedo escribir en
base 2 esto es lo mismo que 2 elevado al
cuadrado 2 elevado al cuadrado es 4 que
multiplica a su vez a 2 elevado a la
equis y esto es igual a 2 elevado a la y
ahora si nos fijamos en la izquierda
podemos utilizar las leyes los
exponentes para reducir esta expresión
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 2 la
base se conserva y ahora que tengo 2
elevado al cuadrado por 2 elevado a la x
las potencias se suma entonces no va a
quedar 2 + x
esto es igual a dos elevadores y ya está
ya que tengo la solución casi la
solución de este problema porque si esta
igualdad es cierta no queda de otra la
paz es la misma y entonces las potencias
también deben ser las mismas para que se
cumpla esta igualdad eso quiere decir
que ya debe de ser igual a 2 más x pero
como lo que yo quiero es x en términos
de james entonces va a quedar x es igual
a de menos 2 y esa es la respuesta este
problema x es igual al menos 2 que por
cierto
es el inciso y ya está es la respuesta a
este problema número 11 vamos a hacer el
problema número 12 el problema número 2
dice si las medidas en grados de los
ángulos de un triángulo cumplen con una
proporción de 2
a
ok en cuántos grados excede el mayor de
los ángulos de este triángulo al menor
de ellos ok si yo tengo un triángulo o
un triángulo como éste la relación entre
los ángulos es de 2 a 3 a 4 entonces
para no complicar más la vida que te
parece si digo que el ángulo menor ni de
2 x este ángulo mide 2 x perfecto si
este medio 2x entonces éste debe medir
3x y éste debe de medir 4x para que
cumplan justo esta relación que tenemos
aquí y ya que ya puedo despejar a x
porque recuerdan que la suma de todos
los ángulos internos de un triángulo me
debe dar 180 es decir 2 x + 3 x + 4 x
esto me debe dar 180 grados
y de aquí dos tres cuatro es lo mismo
que 99 x es igual a 180 grados ok y de
aquí ya puede obtener a x x debe de ser
igual a 20 grados para que se cumpla
esta ecuación y si x es igual a 20
grados entonces este ángulo de aquí mide
40 grados ok este aquí va a medir a 60
grados ok y este va a medir a 80 grados
y fíjate que aquí se cumple en primer
lugar que la suma me da 180 grados y en
segundo lugar que la relación es
234 si dividimos todo entre 20 me
quedaría 2 3 y 4 ok pero ahora lo que me
piden es en cuántos grados se excede el
mayor de los ángulos de este triángulo
el menor de ellos es decir esencialmente
lo que tengo que hacer es tomar 180
menos 40 grados y esto es igual a 40
grados la respuesta a este problema son
40 grados la diferencia entre el ángulo
mayor y el ángulo menor de este
triángulo son 40
y es el insisto de lujo al problema
número 12 vamos a hacer ahora el
problema número 3 que dice
que el precio para llamar de la ciudad a
la ciudad ve es 50 centavos el primer
minuto que voy a escribirlo así 50
centavos puntos 50 el primer minuto y 30
centavos por cada minuto adicional ok
esto quiere decir que si tú llamas un
minuto te cobran 50 centavos los hitos
llamas más de un minuto entonces por
cada uno de los minutos adicionales te
van a cobrar a 30 centavos es decir
punto 30 por la cantidad de minutos
adicionales que tú te tardes imagínate
que yo bautizo a n en la cantidad de
minutos
cantidad
ok entonces si en esa cantidad de
minutos que dura la llamada el primer
minuto te salen 50 centavos y después
todos los demás minutos te salen en 30
centavos pero el primer minuto que
serían 50 centavos por lo tanto a este
punto 30 lo voy a multiplicar por n que
es la cantidad de minutos excepto el
primero m menos 1 esta expresión de aquí
me está diciendo que por cada minuto que
no sea el minuto inicial me van a cobrar
30 centavos y no estoy quitando uno
precisamente porque me voy a tomar todos
los minutos excepto el primero y el
primero me lo van a cobrar a 50 centavos
ok y qué me dice la pregunta cuál de las
siguientes funciones describe el costo
de la llamada en pesos ok esto está dado
en pesos de la ciudad a la ciudad ve
cuya duración sea n minutos de lujo ya
acabamos porque es justo esta exposición
que tengo aquí punto 50 + punto 30 que
multiplica a n -1 y bueno lo único que
quiero que veas es que lo obtuvimos
diciendo tengo que el primer minuto me
cuesta y después a todos los minutos
adicionales en el -1 todos los minutos
que no sean el primer minuto lo voy a
multiplicar por punto 30 que es lo que
vale el minuto adicional y la respuesta
es el inciso c ok a un problema 14 no
creo que el problema 14 lo voy a hacer
en el siguiente vídeo porque solamente
restan 3 problemas para acabar todos los
exámenes y todas las secciones del s
así que en el siguiente vídeo voy a
hacer estos últimos tres problemas
juntos nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo